ich glaube an eine Welt in der wir alle
genügend zu essen haben das ist meine
persönliche Vision und das geht
natürlich auch darum dass wir alle
genügend Bildung haben genügend
Klamotten haben dass wir uns bewegen
können also Mobilität und deswegen bin
ich davon überzeugt dass wenn wir unsere
Ressourcen die wir hier auf dem Planeten
haben und die reichen für alle mehr
gemeinschaftlich nutzen wir alle mehr
davon haben jetzt muss ich aber wissen
wie sie das ganz konkret beispielsweise
wir haben schon angesprochen sie sind
auch Vater von Kindern wie sie das ganz
konkret umsetzen ich kaufe nur
secondhand Sachen für meine Kinder habe
jetzt mit meinem großen aber schon so
ordentlich schon wieder was war schon
einer anhatte also jetzt möchte ich mal
reingehen in ihr reales Leben wir setzen
Sie das um ja also ich glaube erstmal
das wichtigste ist wenn es aus einer
inneren Überzeugung passiert deswegen
erinnere ich mich seit 2010 vegan also
pflanzlich nicht weil irgendwie jemand
gesagt hat du musst sondern ich darf und
ich habe die Möglichkeiten mich
ausreichend genügend gesund zu ernähren
auch auf rein pflanzlicher Ebene das
gleiche ist über Klamotten ich kaufe
auch mal neue Unterhosen neue Socken
aber wir haben ja eine Millionen Tonnen
im Textilien die wir jedes in
Deutschland wegschmeißen obwohl die noch
im besten oder viele davon im super
guten Zustand sind das heißt wenn man
das über ein Bewusstseinswandel im Kopf
den Kindern vielleicht auch also unsere
jetzt elf und acht und die die kennen
gar nichts anderes die haben auch schon
mal ein neues Kleidungsstück gehabt aber
für die ist das ganze mal und die wissen
auch dass ein Kilo Baumwolle mehr als
15.000 Liter Wasser verbraucht und zwar
nicht hier in Europa sondern die
Baumwolle kommt in der Regel aus Afrika
wo wiederum Menschen hungern und dann im
Grundwasser nicht mehr so viel Wasser da
ist oder im Fluss oder im See das heißt
auch diese Zusammenhänge den Kindern
mitzugeben und nicht so mit einer Keule
hey du darfst nur das oder wir haben
kein Geld für sein nee wir wollen das
und wenn dann diese Überzeugung von den
Eltern die soll das natürlich am besten
Vorleben auch bei den Kindern ankommt
dann macht das Klamotten tragen von
schon genutzten Klamotten oder auch
elektronischen Dingen die wir auch noch
zeigen kennen kaufen Bücher kann man
gebraucht kaufen wir haben in Europa
oder hier in Deutschland mit Momox oder
Medimops der größten perfekten
Handbücher Laden Online-Shop der Welt wo
hunderte Millionen Bücher haben und ich
glaube wenn wir anfangen auch bei uns
selbst zu schauen was habe ich
eigentlich in meinem Haushalt an Büchern
an Klamotten an Dingen die ich nicht
mehr brauche und die wieder in den
Kreislauf zurückgebe dann können wir
alle auch eine Welt schaffen in der wir
alle Internet haben in der wir uns alle
kleiden können und trotzdem werden
ökologischen Fußabdruck haben der näher
an die drei Tonnen oder zweieinhalb
Tonnen die wir eigentlich nur ausstoßen
dürfen im Moment sind wir bei 10 11
Tonnen in Deutschland dann kommen wir da
auch näher hin wie soll das mit dem
Teilen funktioniert also ganz konkret
was können wir alles teilen jetzt
Waschmaschine mit einem Nachbarn oder
Auto in einer Gemeinschaft wie kann man
das umsetzen ja letztendlich können wir
alles teilen also wir haben ja zum
Beispiel in deutsche
Lebensmittelverschwendung von 18
Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr das ist eine
volle LKW-Ladung pro Minute die wir
verschwenden und die Hälfte ca der
Lebensmittelverschwendung findet bei uns
zu Hause statt das heißt wir sind alle
Teil des Problems deswegen können wir
auch Teil der Lösung sein ich habe
2012 die Initiative foodsharing mit
aufgebaut das sind mittlerweile 130.000
Menschen aktiv die an den Standorten
Bäckereien Supermärkten Markt standen
Lebensmittel kostenlos abholen wo die
Tafel nicht hingeht und nicht hingehen
kann oder die Uhrzeit nicht passt die
holen die Lebensmittel ab wir haben fast
100 Millionen Kilogramm mittlerweile
gerettet und teilen diese Lebensmittel
das heißt wir haben ja von allem mehr
als verbrauchen das gleiche ist aber für
Kleider da kann ja auch einfach sagen
anstatt die in so ein Container zu
schmeißen wo vielleicht noch irgendwie
eine Polsterung raus wird für ein Auto
und die beste Ware kommt leider auch aus
Europa kann ich vielleicht sagen hey ich
mache in meinem Leben an der Netzwerk im
nachbarschafts WhatsApp Gruppe wo auch
immer ich habe dir Kleider und das das
was schönes ist das heißt so wie ein
Doggy back im Restaurant das nicht
uncool und das ist für ein Hund sondern
ich stehe dazu ich stehe auf gebrauchte
Sachen ich stehe drauf wenn wir uns
gemeinschaftlich mehr helfen und
unterstützen und auch die Ressourcen die
wir in unseren Haushalten haben mehr
teilen und am Ende macht es auch viel
mehr Freude weil wir auch im
menschlichen Kontakt kommen und nicht
nur ist irgendwie online in der Kiste
und dann schicken wir die Hälfte wieder
zurück weil uns die Klamotten nicht
gefallen also das macht er überhaupt
keinen Spaß schon die Umwelt nicht und
das Portemonnaie ebenso nicht haben sie
irgendwas secondhand an oder teilen sie
irgendwas wahrscheinlich würden viele
Menschen sagen auch mit dem Auto von
meinem jenicke
kein Problem
wir haben einen stinke Diesel als
Produktions van wenn wir halt viele
Equipment haben und ansonsten
Elektroauto das teilen wir je nachdem
wie lange fährt ich wohne in der
Wohnanlage mit fünf Wohnung es gibt
einen Waschkeller mit einer
Waschmaschine benutze ich nicht brauche
ich nicht meine Klamotten sind ich würde
sagen zu 80% gebraucht ich kaufe
tatsächlich ganz viel gebraucht bis auf
einmal saubere Socken Unterhose und
T-Shirt und ähm ich bin totaler Fans
braucht noch nicht hier den Rasenmäher
in black and Decker Bohrer also ich
gerade Waschmaschine das kann man alles
teilen das ist nicht widerspricht
natürlich unseren Wirtschaftsmodell
woher ständig wachsen mehr verkaufen
sobald der Konsum einbricht gibt es ja
eine Wallstreet der Börse Panikattacken
ich glaube dass ich hier ein Modell sind
eigentlich das einzige Modell wie wir
tatsächlich nicht weiterkommen das gilt
für Möbel man kann ja wirklich alles
mittlerweile gebrauchen kaufen ich
glaube man braucht sehr wenig Dinge
tatsächlich neu
man kann natürlich getragene Kleidung
abgeben das machen wir bei uns in der
Kirchgemeinde umsonst und dann kriegen
auch die anderen Leute das umsonst die
müssen das nicht kaufen das ist etwas
was es schon seit Jahrhunderten oder
Jahrzehnten gibt das ist gepflegt also
sag mal aus christliche Tradition aus
meiner Sicht das nächste ist aber es
gibt natürlich den starken Wunsch auch
individuell zu sein und der wird sich
auch weltweit durchsetzen die Leute
wollen frei sein wollen individuell sein
bei 8 Milliarden wird spannend und das
bedeutet aus meiner Sicht dass man sich
natürlich in der Kleidung unterscheiden
möchte in diesem jenen man kann über
praktische ich bin kein Auto Fanatiker
aber ich habe mein eigenes Auto ich
brauche aber auch beruflich war sehr
viel gerade im ländlichen Raum dann muss
man das haben aus meiner Sicht sonst
geht es nicht aber jetzt angenommen es
gibt da jemand der sagt oh ich habe ein
Auto und das teile ich auch mit zwei
Leuten und das frisst dann bei einer
Ladung so viel Strom wie 3000 Handy
aufgeladen werden müssen dann frage ich
mich wer sie nicht lüge auf das E-Auto
zu verzichten oder lieber bei
Digitalisierung voranzu machen ist das
nicht schlauer also die Frage steht ja
nicht nur ob ich auf irgendwas
verzichtet indem ich es Teil die frage
ich ob ich bestimmte Entwicklung
überhaupt weiter mache wir haben ein
Stromproblem das werden auch die
nächsten Jahre noch haben warum machen
wir dann so viel Geld Investitionen in
einen Bereich über diesen E-Autos wo
dann jetzt der Chef von Netzagentur sagt
na ja die müssen sowieso abschalten wenn
kein Wind teilen können
Individualismus dann ist meine Frage
warum sie in Amsterdam wo ich regelmäßig
Arbeiten jeder zweite Laden mittlerweile
Vintage ist und die gesamten
Jugendlichen holland kaufen alles alles
Leute kommen natürlich auch eine andere
Lebenssituation das hat damit zu tun
dass wir natürlich weniger in der Lage
sind die Bedürfnisse noch so abzudecken
wir haben eine hohe Überschuldung des
Staates wir haben die demografische
Entwicklung jetzt wird schon angefangen
zu sagen Alter Ehepaare soll mal aus
ihrem großen Wohnungen ausziehen soll
lieber ein kleinere ziehen das heißt die
individuellen Lebens Entwürfe werden
gerade sehr eingesammelt und zwar mit
moralischer Argumentation ich finde das
nicht in Ordnung und deswegen ist die
Frage wer was teilen möchte soll das
machen ich habe auch eine Weile Autos
Carsharing mitgemacht zum Beispiel habe
meine Erfahrung damit gesammelt habe es
dann wieder abgewählt aus verschiedenen
Gründen man kann wie gesagt Kleidung
Spenden das ist aber kein Thema mache
ich auch ist alles nicht das Thema aber
das klingt jetzt so als würde wenn du
das nicht machst dann bist du ja so ein
blöder Individualist oder sowas gesagt
ich hätte gerne eine Klarheit
kein Problem passt das in die Vielfalt
unsere Lebensentwürfe bin ich voll dabei
die Frage die ich sehe ist ähm ist es
jetzt sozusagen eine Mission ist allen
anderen auch noch über zu helfen oder
ist man damit zufrieden dass man selber
hingekriegt hat
da kommen wir auch gleich zur Feuerwehr
aber Frank ist das für sie ein gutes
Konzept dass wir mehr teilen Sie etwas
also die die Klamotten gehen zum DRK
traditionell und wir trennen natürlich
auch Müll das ist ja alles eigentlich
ganz normales Kind
in dem Bereich sind wir ja bewusst und
das kriegt auch meine Tochter mit also
und die verfärbt da ganz genauso im
Gegenteil insofern das Problem ist das
was Sie angesprochen haben wenn das eine
individuelle Lösung ist und wenn sie
dort so viele Leute wenn sie wenn sie
Nahrungsmittel ab und das finde ich
alles kann ich alles unterstützen aber
diese Gleichmacherei die die richtig
gleich mal alle über einen Kamm
geschossen werden wenn das nur so
individuell ist wie sie sagen es ist
okay ich kenne genügend Leute die
arbeiten hat die möchten sich was
eigenes Schaffen die möchten den eigenen
Wagen haben möchten niemanden dabei
haben weil die alle meine negative
Erfahrung gemacht oder auch nicht ja
sondern die möchten den eigenen
individuellen Weg gehen und dann da da
soll er Arbeit sich und Leistung auch
lohnen und darum haben wir eine andere
lebensverfassung und das muss man den
lassen und so oder so lange sie das
tolerieren dass jeder machen kann ist
okay ich habe nur die Angst die wir ja
diese moralische kommt dass man in den
Medien auch so dermaßen getrieben wird
dass man sagt oh ich dachte das muss ich
das alles anders machen sonst habe ich
das Problem